hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
today I'm going to be talking about a
boon to foam now a lot of people have
been asking me to do a video on a
Bluetooth phone as it's kind of coming
into its broadest light recently it's
been very popular it was at CES where a
lot of people got their first hands on
and first impressions of it but
basically it's really new thing so let's
go and talk about it what is it well
first of all it's an operating system
ubuntu phone is the name just like we
see Windows Phone on all Windows Phone
phones we see iOS on every iPhone we see
Android on a ton of phones so a boon to
phone is a new operating system that
will run on other phones now what
devices and phones will it run on well
that's a good question because it's not
completely answered yet but in all the
demos we've seen in all the videos of at
CES and everything it's running on a
Samsung Galaxy Nexus which is Google's
last generation development phone not to
say it's an old or a bad phone but it's
one year old hardware now reporting to
Joe no bacon who is community manager
over there for a Bluetooth there are
three possible ways that this could work
number one is that there will be phones
like the Galaxy Nexus that currently run
Android they will be able to run a boon
to phone so just nothing but a boon to
phones just the plain operating system
and that will be the only OS that they
run not the iPhone Blackberry is not
Windows Phone just phones that are
capable of running Android will be
capable of running just a boon to phone
option number two is something I'd like
to see is higher-end phones with you
know quad-core processors and extra RAM
these Android phones would run Android
in your pocket but then when you hook
them up to a dock and a desktop maybe a
display you'll be able to run a full
version of desktop of boot to Linux so
it's an Android phone in your pocket but
it's also a desktop PC when you hook it
up to a dock and a keyboard in a display
and the third way is certain devices
will be able to run a boon to phone in
your pocket and be able to dock and run
the full version of Mbutu on your
desktop with terminal and everything so
if you're ready for that that's
definitely going to be the full complete
experience and I think that's what
they're going to be aiming for but I
definitely like option number two with a
high-end Android phone being able to
dock and suddenly run a boot to on the
desktop and also an unofficial
prediction for me I kind of have a
feeling we're going to be seeing this on
tablets soon as well this year just
because of how thumb friendly the OS is
but we'll get to that in a second you
should also know that a boon to phone is
an open-source operating system the same
way Android
and what that means for Android is that
manufacturers can come in and spin it
however they want and then output that
and it'll be different variations of
Android in the end same thing will
probably possible with Ubuntu phone
there will be different spins of it
different variations of it or maybe just
certain customizations that developers
will be able to add maybe you want a
lock screen to look a certain way or
you'll be able to change things
basically the same way you can with
Android so what makes this different
from Android well the biggest difference
I see with Android is the user interface
user interface is really clean really
simple but it's also got a little bit of
a learning curve to it it doesn't use
any actual buttons no capacitive or
software buttons the only buttons that
you use are the actual power and volume
buttons on the phone the hands-on demos
with it haven't been super smooth we've
seen a lot of frame stuttering and
things like that but again this is very
alpha this is way pre-release and I've a
certain feeling that this is going to be
as smooth as anything else out there
when it hits market also something
notable about it is that there's no
central home location or home button
there's home screens but there's no pone
button that you can stamp and go home
the same way you see on Android there's
a home button you can go home on iOS
it's just always a physical circular
home button that you can go home even on
Windows Phone you have a certain button
you press to go home that doesn't exist
on a Bluetooth phone so if you're
familiar with Ubuntu and Linux you
probably won't have a problem with this
but you should note that that it's going
to have a little bit of a learning curve
so without any further ado here are my
top 5 features of a boon to phone
starting with number 5 and that's the
color scheme now this might seem minor a
lot of people are like oh the color
scheme that's nice but a lot of people
who are already using Ubuntu or Linux on
their desktops are familiar with that
orange and you know that it's a
good-looking color scheme I have to
admit and you know running on black
phone so it's a black bezel with the
orange wallpapers I don't know it just
looks pretty good I thought it was
notable number 4 is the built-in apps
and they were doing a lot of these at
the demo at CES that I got to look at
and especially things like the gallery
app it just looks really I don't know it
looks clean it looks intuitive but again
it's different so you're going to have
to learn it but I think the built-in
apps were noteworthy especially things
like the gallery app which just it just
struck me as being different the number
three feature is multitasking and this
is done really well very similar in fact
to Chrome for Android when you swipe in
from the
right hand side you'll be able to swipe
between your open applications so you'll
cycle through those by swiping in from
the right-hand side of the display it
looked pretty smooth again not as smooth
as probably the final release but it did
look pretty good and but this is
slightly incomplete I feel like because
there was no real way to close open
things just like in Chrome for Android
you can close your existing tabs but
when you switch between these you don't
really have a way to close open
applications you can just cycle between
the ones that are open so it's nice the
way it works but I think when it's
complete it will have a way to close
apps so that's pretty cool that brings
us to number two the number two feature
is just the overall guest or based UI so
I said there are no real buttons
involved only the power and volume
buttons so the way you get around this
is using the swipes from the top bottom
and left and right edges of your display
so I've been from the bottom and that'll
bring you to your menu that's a
contextual menu so if save here in the
gallery and you swipe in from the bottom
you might get a share menu to be able to
share that photo or edit that photo or
video that you're looking at if you saw
I've been from the right that's where
you get your multitasking so you'll be
able to cycle between open applications
and swipe in from the left and that's
where you get your basically your app
launcher so clapping in from the left
here will allow you to crawl up and down
and open whatever app you have Facebook
camera gallery browser whatever you want
and you'll be able to open this just
from the launcher on the left hand side
that launcher on the Left wall so you be
able to bring you to the desktop the one
of the essentially home screens on a
Bluetooth phone and on the top that
brings us to our number one that is your
settings toggles which are brilliant the
settings toggles in a Bluetooth phone
gives you really really fast but also
really quick and intuitive access to
your settings basically you swipe down
from the top and then before you go all
the way down you swipe to the left or to
the right to pick the setting you want
to adjust and then swipe all the way
down to get access to it so it's very
very specific gives you a lot of control
and a lot more options actually than the
quick Android 4.2 settings pretty much
every other OS is really far behind in
terms of quick settings toggles and
controls so right above Android I would
put a boon to phones quick settings
toggles they are good looking they are
fast and they are smooth and they are
really useful so I like that that's my
number one feature so there I go guys
that's the new player in the market a
bunch of phone should be coming out on
some unknown
range of devices later this year what do
you guys think about it I mean I
personally think I want to try this I'm
not one to really play around with a ton
of different operating systems I've
stuck two maybe three total on my phones
Windows Phone Android and iOS but I
don't know I think I would give this a
try this year considering whatever
devices it runs on especially if it uses
that second option where it can be maybe
Android in your pocket and then a Mbutu
on the desktop that seems that seems
cool so either way if you enjoyed this
video feel free to give it a thumbs up
below or a +1 or if you learn something
feel free to reshare it definitely helps
out a lot with the channel either way
thank you for watching and I will talk
to you guys in the next video